Disney what's not to love a the house of
mass has given us some of the most
beloved films of all time with the
wholesome mix of charming animation
memorable characters and horrible show
tunes look for the bare necessities the
simple bare necessities and their eye
again this week with mana which delves
into the mythology of Maui a demigod
from the South Pacific directors Ron
Clements and John Musker who gave us the
Little Mermaid and Aladdin actually
travelled out to the South Pacific twice
to make sure they were doing the stories
justice and by justice we mean Disney
Justice which involves taking these guys
and making their stories a little more
wholesome for the family some of the
most popular tunes have bastardized not
only the Brothers Grimm but Hans
Christian Andersen and Victor Hugo among
others if you played The Witcher threes
blood and wine you may have had a
glimpse at the dark truth behind some of
these fairy tales hey what's up guys
welcome to Tammy plays and we are
playing Witcher 3 blood and wine we're
gonna see Rapunzel who's a straight
hottie if you've seen tangled you know
she is a banger here we go Rapunzel baby
oh my god why is going on here why is
she
that's just one example of Disney's
sugar coin here are five more viewer
beware
your outlook on life may be
fundamentally damaged after watching
this
Sleeping Beauty as written by gam gam
but Batista bazzill features one of the
most morally reprehensible Kings in all
fairy tale fiction like in the Disney
version
she's pricked by splinter and falls into
a slumber her father deals with this in
the very normal way of seating her on a
velvet throne and then abandoning her in
a house forever sometime later another
King stumbles upon her and tries to wake
her but ultimately fails now it's about
to get real nasty in here so if you
don't want your lovely childhood
memories of this story ruined then look
away now and kuvira's as well the King
actually impregnate Sleeping Beauty
while she's unconscious and then just
returns to his kingdom she gives birth
to two children sun and moon while still
in her coma
one of the kids manages to save her life
by sucking the splinter out of her
finger which wakes our up to a world
where she's a mother of two and has no
idea who the father is things end up
relatively happy after the Kings
illegitimate children are saved from
being cooked into pies and Sleeping
Beauty escapes being burned alive at the
hands of the jealous Queen but it's hard
to get over just how awful the Kings
behavior was so she's unconscious he
impregnates her she gives birth while
still unconscious
none of this story is okay when you are
the best of friends
having so much
the last time I watched the Disney movie
the Fox and the Hound I wept like a baby
what 25th birthday that was but I had no
idea the novel behind the film was so so
much worse like the Disney film there
are two hunting dogs chief and cover and
one red fox named Todd who revels in
tormenting the hounds they're chained up
at the farm that is until one day he
made man chief decides to break free and
chase the Fox Todd after the Fox jumps
to train tracks in the chase chief
attempts to follow and is killed by the
locomotive with his favorite dog dead
the master promises revenge and the Fox
that killed his beloved hunting
companion what follows is years and
years and winters and winters a revenge
filled frenzied fox hunting even going
as far as only training the remaining
dog copper to just punt Todd in their
quest for revenge master and copper head
out into the woods to find Todd pushing
harder and harder for hours and hours
until Todd can run no more and falls
down dead from exhaustion with Todd dead
the master nurses copper back to health
before returning to his alcoholic ways
but when his deteriorating health forces
him to move to a nursing home that
unfortunately doesn't allow dogs he
takes his shotgun from the wall leaves
copper outside and pets him ever so
gently before ordering him to lie down
wouldn't cry making this video but if
there's one thing that always gets me
it's those poor dead animals
dead animals and onions how am I talking
to love onions
The Hunchback of Nitra Don the
heartwarming tale of Quasimodo a
deformed outcast that becomes a hero to
the people that once shunned him but
what if I told you that story is a lie
Quasimodo is a [ __ ] and he's also a bit
of a creep see in the cute and colorful
Disney version Quasimodo comes to accept
that as Murrell de a beautiful gypsy
girl that captures his heart is in love
with someone else and gives the happy
couple his blessing
it's a classic Disney fairy tale that
ends with everyone living happily ever
after but in Victor Hugo's original
version of the story it doesn't quite
wrap up as nicely as that oh no in fact
the original ending is decidedly more
tragic with Esmeralda being hanged by
Claude Frollo who kills her because
she's not interested in him what a loser
in that version the simple-minded
Quasimodo basically delivers as Morell
doe to her death and only realizes his
mistake when he notices Frollo laughing
at the limp lifeless body of his gypsy
love interest Quasimodo becomes the
mayor of creep town by then going to the
graveyard whereas merle does body is
dumped and laying down next to her he
stays there until he dies of starvation
and their bodies are discovered over a
year later with skeletons entwined I
don't know about you but I'm glad I
never saw that version of the story as a
kid
weird gross stuff that washes up on the
shores of beaches and the wave comes in
that we had seafoam that's dead mermaids
q Disney and the narwhal you rode in on
you never mentioned that in your vision
but that's the kicker in the original
fairy tale from the Danish author Hans
Christian Andersen that version sees the
Little Mermaid give up her 300 year long
life in the sea to have a human soul and
all for the love of a smarmy prince that
she saves but here is where it gets
really nasty a small print in this deal
dictates that she'll have a tongue cut
out and lose her beautiful voice every
step will feel like she is walking on
sharp knives he only gets her soul after
the prince marries her and if he falls
for another her heart will break she
will die and then dissolve into seafoam
damn hands screwed up imagination
for the most part Disney's take on
Cinderella is in line with the Brothers
Grimm it just leaves out all the
self-mutilation there's also the matter
of Cinderella's father being alive in
the Brothers Grimm version and him being
a bit of a [ __ ] bag after Cinderella's
mother dies he remarries which is where
the pretty faced butt cold-hearted
stepsisters come in they abuse innocent
Cinderella forcing her to work non-stop
calling her name's and generally making
her life a living hell from there things
go pretty much as you know it Cyndi is
magically transformed into a beautiful
fair maiden she captures his heart but
vanishes just before midnight on each
day leaving her slippers behind on the
3rd but things get a bit gruesome from
this point when the Prince shows up to
Cindy's house to find his would-be Queen
one of the stepsisters cuts off her own
toes so she can fit into the slippers
and live a life of luxury and privilege
take it away
Jamie the Prince sees through the ruse
and moves on to the other sister who
tries cutting off part of a heal instead
the third time is a charm however and
the slipper fits things end happily
we've Cindy marrying the Prince and then
commanding some doves to peck out her
stepsisters eyes and you know what we
don't blame her
so there you are the gross and slightly
disturbing origins of five of your
favorite Disney movies sorry for any
childhood trauma
we've caused for more videos like this
one make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
GameSpot and gamespot universe and we'll
see you next time